hi I'm Mike bigam and I feel ambitious
about being Conan O'Brien's friend
ambitious that's interesting as if we're
not already friendly people you know
we're friendly we know each other I'm
looking to take it to the next level oh
I like that maybe uh maybe I'm not ready
for that we have to see through the
course of this of this discussion
whether you and I whether I'm ready to
take it to the next level with Mike
biglia here's what happened last time
I'm going to bring the listeners up to
speed um I challenged you on the idea of
the concept of the show that you want to
be friends and I said I don't have your
contact information and you said it and
then you bleeped it but then we were in
touch and I just want to read a text
chain that we had because I'm in
addition to being a a second time guest
on the show I'm a a Avid listener I love
the Steven Wright episode oh thank you
so good yeah he was wonderful wonderful
to Conan and I said Stephen writes the
reason I got into comedy and listening
it was the best interview I've ever
heard of Stephen Wright because he
laughed and I'd never I'd never heard
him laugh before and I've been a fan of
because I feel like I've seen every
interview so you like killed him and
then um and then I and then I wrote this
to you and you wrote I'm actually in New
York right now cranking out pods taking
meetings I'm in Midtown my daughter
shows up today but leaves Monday if
there's a chance to grab coffee it'd be
nice to catch up yeah so that was like a
friendship move we had we had never had
coffee I tried to take it to the next
level did you really say cranking out
pods I'm cranking out pods but that
didn't mean
podcasts I did you know that did you
guys know that I I manufacture instant
coffee
pods and then so I make a decaf pod
that's quite popular that's the best
version of what I was imagining yeah
yeah you don't know about C- pods C-
pods are huge cods are massive in Brazil
guess what they're about to be Starbucks
Starbucks is about to carry them no
actually in Brazil they drink cop pods
that are manufactured here by Conan at
his house yeah in coffee that's coffee
that's grown naturally in Brooklyn
Massachusetts I have a I have a coffee
plantation in Brooklyn Mass copons are
90% dust yeah yeah well we're going to
get that up to 94% dust cuz the profit
the profit margin on C- pods is
extraordinary like you've never seen
anything like it yeah because because
Brooklyn Massachusetts and I also have a
Plantation uh in uh in Newton Mass these
are not good places to grow coffee so I
get very few beans so that's why we need
to supplement with dust okay yeah anyway
it's a long story one for every Bean
they're Logan is for every Bean we'll
give you a bag of dust
yes beat that slogan I've challenged
Madison Avenue to beat that slogan and
they can't do it they get their best
people on it okay there's more to the
text there's more to the text okay by
the way I'm team Sona
today team son
mug I'm also team mat oh thanks those
mugs really uh they don't went missing I
think you're missing the point
though that he's team son and team Matt
and I don't see a team Matt mug I've
never seen one okay so so you go I'm
here I'm here P you know I'm here
podcasting um and then you wrote text me
when you're back and I'll ghost you yes
and then I wrote I've been ghosted by
much bigger celebrities than you yep I
it bounces off of me and you wrote it'll
sting you'll
see and then God I'm killing myself here
and then uh and then uh and then you
said I'll be back mid June because I was
trying to get you to come back on
working it out my podcast which which I
want I'm still going to try to get you
to come back on yep and then um when you
were back uh you ghosted me yeah and it
did Sting so
today what I want to do is engage try to
get you back on my podcast and also for
this for pods okay coffee coffee pod
listen uh first of all um so you were
waiting for me to reach out to you when
I came back in June no I texted you then
oh yeah yeah yeah and what did you say
how did you know I was in town because
you had written mid June around the 13th
I wrote okay perfect can't wait yeah so
then but when I hear can't wait that
don't put this back on him no no no but
listen when I hear can't wait that's
it's that just is too irresistible when
someone someone says I can't wait that
makes me think oh you're going to
wait you know what I mean biglia
right yes this is the real me you want
the real me this is why Sona is so hard
on you yes that is exactly why son you
know me the minute I saw can't wait
there was part of me that was like
there's certain things you just hate
that really like bug you no one
understands it God damn it you need to
reply to him from now on with can wait M
then I can't wait yeah let uh
one of the things you wrote is let's try
to make that work all I ask is that I
feature prominently in your next oneman
show yes that's good that's good this is
don't you think this is better than
meeting up with me in person this is
better these are classic quips and I
wrote yes you're the second man top
billing you'll have to
audition
um I you know what I am going to be uh
well this is the problem I'm going to be
coming to but I don't know when this
airs but after we gotten back yeah after
we've gotten back so I will be in
Brooklyn cranking out pods cranking out
Pods at the Brooklyn Academy of Music
with uh my team here uh uh Team Sona and
and team gorle but um that's like a
quick turnaround that's two days and
then gone do you ever get over to
Brooklyn that's where I live I knew that
on our I knew that made it so clear cuz
I was going to take you for a nice
dinner at lucali Pizzeria in the
neighborhood days free he's got the days
free oh he has the days free do the days
yeah let's do the days do you want to do
the days yeah I want to do by the time
people listen you know what's great that
by the time people hear this I will have
been to Brooklyn and ghosted you
again and it will and it will have stung
oh this will sting so much because
you'll you'll see me as I'm ghosting you
you'll see me in the glass in the
Pizzeria and you'll be outside it'll be
be shivering cold because it's November